pour en parler nous sommes avec ludovic
emmanueli président de croissance pis
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous ce
matin le conflit oppose donc deux
communautés de l'ituri les lendo qui
sont majoritairement agriculteurs et les
ema qui sont plutôt éleveurs et
commerçants comment est ce qu'on
explique les origines du conflit ce que
c'est une résurgence las de la guerre
d'ituri qui qui avec s'étaient déroulés
entre 99 et 2003 alors quelque part oui
mais quelles sont les raisons en 1950 en
1960 70 avait pas ce genre de 2,2 de
combat entre les deux ethnies il y avait
2 des combats sporadiques
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
qu'actuellement dans cette région on a
du coltan on adore on a du bois on a
tout un tas de choses de de bois
précieux il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent et un certain nombre de
d'organiser ont tout intérêt à essayer
de prendre le maximum et donc opposent
parfois les communautés où les ethnies
de manière à pouvoir rentrer d'une
manière plus facile dans ce genre de
région alors à l'époque l'onu et
l'europe avait eu beaucoup de mal à
mettre un terme à la guerre
la cour pénale internationale est
d'ailleurs toujours en train de juger
des crimes qui ont été commis
éviter un nouvel embrasement de l'ituri
c'est ce qui explique aussi aujourd'hui
la visite de michelle bachelet dans
cette région oui tout à fait alors ça
c'est à la demande du président de rdc
il faut savoir quand même que ce pays a
un gros gros problème vous avez un homme
qui a été élu tout à fait légalement à
la tête de la rdc
mais son concurrent et ancien président
sont sur des positions qui sont un peu
différentes
ils disent tous les deux 2023 mais en
attendant 2023 et bien qu'ils se mettent
des peaux de banane sous des pâtes et
qu'est ce qui se passe on a une espèce
de coalition qui est
assez atypique où vous avez un président
qui est président vous avez un ministre
des finances qui est ministre des
finances pro-kabila mini désarmé
également pro kabila est donc le
président actuel a de grosses
difficultés à gérer son pays et donc ce
qui explique également qu'il a des
difficultés à régler tous les problèmes
en écurie est les tensions sont
réellement croissante au sein de la
coalition ou un risque qu'elles ne
s'aggravent
il ya un risque et ça grave puisqu'il ya
des intérêts divergents ils ont fait une
coalition où ils se sont embrassés il ya
eu des accolades on est soi disant tout
ce copain mais visiblement gamin qui
veut revenir au pouvoir et l'eau qui va
essayer de faire un certain nombre de
choses je vous donne est juste un
exemple vous avez le président
actuellement qui a voulu gratuité au
niveau des écoles de l'enseignement et
de l'éducation etc ministre des finances
ta pro kabila et qu'est ce qu'il fait et
va y sert lévis et il ne donne pas les
budgets alors comment voulez vous qu'on
s'organise
parce qu'on le rappelle 1,7 et il ya un
nom joseph kabila a laissé la place à
l'opposant un félix tshisekedi
c'était la première transition sans
effusion de sang depuis l'indépendance
du pays en 1960
quel bilan est ce que vous vous faites
aujourd'hui de cette première année au
pouvoir
il a beaucoup de volonté beaucoup de
bonne volonté on veut faire beaucoup de
choses
mais la coalition je sais pas si pour le
peuple
de rdc c'est une bonne chose quand il ya
un patron il faut que le patron puisse
faire ce pour quoi il a été élu
et pour le moment il ne fait pas ce
pourquoi il a été est actuellement ce
président devrait en mesure il est
africain de régler les problèmes dans
son pays
c'est un africain qui doit régler ses
problèmes de rdc la communauté
internationale c'est pour régler les
problèmes avec l'international mais lui
doit prendre aux mesures toutes les
difficultés du pays qu'il a voulu réseau
qui s'est présenté il a été élu sidwaya
les ce qui signifie aussi qu'il faut
impliquer les communautés locales pour
mettre un terme au conflit dans les
tours et avalé locale bien entendu il
faut réunir les deux ethnies des deux
ethnies essayer de leur expliquer qu'ils
ne sont que la partie immergée de
l'iceberg
c'est eux qui quittent finalement ce
sont les populations qui s'ouvre le sous
sol lui il va profiter à ceux qui
viendront prendre alors pour revenir sur
les tensions à la tête de l'exécutif le
chef de l'état a envisagé pour la
première fois publiquement de dissoudre
l'assemblée nationale en cas de crise
persistante avec ses partenaires au
pouvoir qui contrôle le parlement avec
un rappel de solides relais dans les
forces de l'ordre qu'est ce que ça peu à
quel genre de situation ce que ça peut
amener alors le problème je vous ai dit
c'est qu'il ya quatre villas d'un côté
les pro kabila et kabila et vous avez le
président actuel les deux sont opposés
façons opposées
il ya une coalition de façade mais qui
ne permet aucune résolution de problèmes
quand vous avez la cour
constitutionnelle quand vous avez le
ministère des finances le ministère des
armées qui sont à la botte de de
l'ancien opposant et donc de celui qui
va se présenter par la suite aux
présidentielles en 2023 ça crée un
climat qui est malsain la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale c'est ce qui a été
proposé et 10 par le président actuel
pense pas qu'il le fasse tout de suite
nos bout d'un moment il va falloir
qu'ils tranchent dans l'art pour essayer
de pardonnez moi ces expressions enfin
au moins elles sont claires qu'ils
prennent des décisions drastiques pour
pouvoir assumer ses fonctions
merci pour votre éclairage ludovic
emmanuël et je rappelle que cette
président de croissanceplus merci